[Applause]
[Music]
here's a question for all of you what
brand is your mobile phone hello now I
guess many of you will probably answer
Apple Samsung or highway Howie
away how do I know well no I'm not a
psychic or anything like that you
probably knew that
I know because year after year these
three companies have led sales in the
global phone market together they sell
approximately half of all smart phones
in the world although due to recent
events things could change a lot the
point is that we're talking about a huge
market here it's estimated that in 2018
the number of smartphone users reached
the staggering figure of three billion
people China tops the list of most users
worldwide almost 780 million Chinese use
a smartphone every day and not only that
China has also become a key player in
the industry for example it's the
country of origin of some of the largest
smartphone manufacturers in the world
we're talking about companies like
Huawei and ZTE so you know we're in
China these devices manufactured yep
it's in the city of Shenzhen better
known as China's Silicon Valley now
we've told you about this incredible
place in several previous videos we've
also told you how in just 40 years
Shenzhen has gone from being a small
fishing town to becoming a mega city
that specializes in advanced technology
it's one of the fastest-growing places
on the planet in case of um seen those
videos I will leave a link to several
related videos in the description
[Music]
and it isn't just Chinese companies like
hallway or ZTE even Apple and Samsung
work with a lot of suppliers in this
city
this means that practically all of us
are in one way or another dependent on
Shenzhen we use these cities products
constantly every day 24/7 in other words
we always have a little bit of Shenzhen
in our hands so how exactly did this
enormous transformation take place is it
a unique case in the world's and the
most important question of all what on
earth has Shenzhen got to do with
Honduras one of the poorest countries in
the Americas if not the world I'll
listen up the seed of change we told you
before here on visual politic at the
beginning of the 1980s the then Chinese
President Deng Xiaoping created a
special economic zone on the border with
Hong Kong in Shenzhen it was the first
of many areas that would later spread
throughout China now just a moment now
many of you might be thinking well what
exactly is a special economic zone
[Music]
well a special economic zone is
basically a defined geographical area
within a country where the rules for
doing business difference usually much
less restrictive than in the rest of the
country these zones were designed as a
way to boost trade and investments they
have clear geographical limits different
rules regulations into their own
administrative system in short we're
talking about territories designed to
target business production and
investments so in China's case these
places became capitalist havens within a
completely socialist model and you know
what they were a huge success the
opening of these economic zones
attracted a huge amount of investments
of both Chinese and foreign capital all
this investment attracted thousands of
immigrants and drove the construction of
factories and homes by the mid 1990s
Shenzhen already has 3 million
inhabitants and an extraordinarily
dynamic economy
the process continues to this day
Shenzhen currently has 12 million
residents which rises to 15 million
during the summer and fall season when
factories work exhaustively to meet the
demand for electronic gifts for
Christmas Santa Claus he cannot forget
all these smartphones drones and latest
generation gadgets that are sold during
the holiday season like there was no
tomorrow however China hasn't been the
only country to bet on this model
another example could be found in the
United Arab Emirates especially in the
emirate of Dubai if you're a fan of this
channel you would have heard us talking
about this in other videos for example
there's Jebel Ali or Dubai's financial
center the lacet not only has its own
regulations but it even has its own
courts it also includes reduced to
bureaucracy fewer taxes and a lot of
legal security and simple procedures to
do business so what more could he really
want while the fact is that the strategy
to diversify the UAE economy beyond oil
was based fundamentally on these special
economic zones of which there are
currently more than a 45 throughout the
country the results the Emirates have
had the highest economic growth in the
entire region since 1980 during this
time its GDP has multiplied by no less
than 10
now just a second does this mean that
the opening of special economic zones is
a recipe for success while sadly this
doesn't seem to be the case for a
special economic zone to really work it
needs to meet certain requirements it
needs to manage itself with complete
autonomy have good infrastructure that
needs to be a lot of legal security a
lot of economic freedom low taxes little
bureaucracy and enough lands to expand
so far we've seen two success stories
China and the UAE now can we find a case
where this strategy has failed and
certainly we can we just have to look to
India
[Music]
well certainly we can in a way India has
historically been an example not to
follow allow me to explain India
established its first special economic
zones back in the 1960s much earlier
than China in fact sit could be
considered a pioneer in the strategy
however in spite of its head start by
the year 2000 there were barely seven
zones operating throughout the country
with much much more modest results than
those of the Chinese example well these
areas they didn't manage to eliminate
bureaucracy they didn't work
autonomously they have limited space and
they operated with far too many
restrictions basically instead of
special economic zones they worked
shelled areas this is one of the reasons
that China has grown so much more than
India in recent decades
[Music]
[Applause]
now hold on a second because if you made
it this far you're probably thinking
well Simon what on earth does all of
this have to do with Honduras when
you're gonna get to Honduras okay so
listen up
[Music]
the Honduran experiment reality or
fiction
especially economic zones are very
popular in the world of international
trade since the 1980s they've sprouted
up like weeds in 1986 the International
Labour Organization reported 176 areas
in 47 countries and in 2006 there were
already more than 3,500 in 130 countries
currently in Latin America it is
estimated that there are more than 300
special economic zones more than half of
these are located in Central America of
course as you might imagine they have
much more restrictive conditions than in
China Latin governments they love to
control everything or at least they love
trying to however there is a country
that has put a plan on the table to
change the situation and their countries
on Duras Honduras is one of the poorest
countries in the entire region it's a
country where the vast majority of the
population live in poverty it also has
enormous rates of violence in every year
tens of thousands of people try to
escape the country in search of a better
life usually to the United States I have
to try new migrant Caravan leaves
Honduras and heads for the United States
violence and gangs obscure life in
Honduras well in recent years Honduras
has presented an ingenious plan to try
and change this situation a plan in
which the American economist Paul Romer
winner of the Nobel Prize in Economics
in 2018 has played a prominent role the
strategy consists of creating zones of
employment and economic developments
throughout the country now what exactly
are the seeds well along the same lines
that we talked about and given that
things don't work in Honduras seeds are
a kind of experiment aimed jump-starting
economic activity so it can grow it from
scratch in some areas of the country
that is leads will be areas in the
Honduran national territory that will
have special regulations and their own
institutions to guarantee security both
physical and legal and a lot more ease
of doing business as everything would
start from scratch it wouldn't be
necessary to change the entire national
system which seems impossible due to all
the existing interests the idea is that
these seeds will attract a lot of
investments and create many jobs so that
they can create a change in the rest of
the country this is what happens with
China's special economic zones the seeds
will have their own legal personality
will be administered autonomously and
are authorized to establish their own
policies and regulations and not only
that they will also have their own
police their own independent courts and
operate under the tradition of
anglo-saxon law known as common law
additionally these areas lands will be
the property of the state but it's
administration will be borne by the
seeds themselves which will define how
that land can be accessed or developed
all of this is in a competitive
framework so that companies and
investors can have the lands they need
for their projects without having to
face heavy urban regulations that could
slow development that way each special
zone can specialize in different
activities will be organized in
different ways to not only compete with
the rest of the world but also compete
with each other
something that would force its
administrators to copy and improve the
best existing policies to attract
investment attracts talents and
ultimately boost the country's
development so pretty smart right we can
imagine that financial centers logistic
centers special tourist areas and even
autonomous cities wait
autonomous cities yep you heard that
right why Limit these special zones to
any companies why not try to build
coexistence models that can work better
than the mess that currently exists in
Honduras these are known as free cities
something that we're going to be talking
about extensively here on visual
politics so please don't forget to
subscribe and click that Bell so you're
up to date with all our new videos but
hold on just a second before you start
ringing bells so this might sound like a
really really attractive project but
isn't it surprising that it's actually
the Honduran personal elite who are
leading this process I mean isn't that a
little bit suspicious
I'm Doren president's brother arrested
in Miami is charged with drug
trafficking well that's exactly what
Paul Romer himself thinks he decided to
distance himself from the project why
well that's because he thinks the
Honduran elite doesn't really want to
promote competition and investments they
want you have a territory that will only
benefit them they have passed a law that
crosses my bright red line it removes
all possibility of electoral
accountability for the people who run
the zone this is not in the law that I
supported I can't tell if what we are
watching is a farce or tragedy it could
end up as farce because I can't imagine
a thoughtful investor would go in and
invest under these circumstances in a
place controlled by a crony aristocracy
Paul Romer and he isn't the only doubter
this projects evolution has raised many
doubts the seeds could even end up
simply being an instrument so that the
oligarchs as always can take over more
sections of the country and stay with
them at will
the lack of transparency and the
country's social conflicts don't seem to
reflect the image of the government's
that seeks to promote developments
[Music]
that's why the initial buzz has been
replaced by disenchantment and suspicion
basically we're presented with a
fantastic idea and possibly a terrible
execution in any case the seeds are
projected to start at the end of 2019 if
they manage to consolidate them and move
forward respecting the spirit of freedom
competition and equality of
opportunities with which the special
economic zones were born we could be
facing a total change of course for
Honduras but at this point it's hard to
be optimistic about this ensure the
question is is on Duras really serious
about creating a model of fully
autonomous seeds without political
interference will Honduras become
Central America's chené chené whatever
the result will be watching on the
progress here a visual politic and I
really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos also please do check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were mine also this Chao is
possible because of patreon hands up
patrons on that platform please do
consider joining them and supporting our
mission for providing independent
political coverage and as always I see
in the next video
[Music]